nadège bonjour alors roye-noyon on le
disait est attendu 10 à l'elysée d'ici
une petite heure qu'en est il et c'est
lui qui s'est autoproclamé président par
intérim du venezuela le 23 janvier 2019
devrait être reçue par emmanuel macron
et d'ici une grosse demi heure ici même
au palais de l'élysée devant lequel je
me trouve les deux hommes ont discuté du
processus électoral à mettre en place au
venezuela
un an après s'être autoproclamé
président par intérim du venezuela juan
garrido n'a pas renversé nicolás maduro
et il est en train de perdre la seule
institution qui lui étaient acquises
jusqu'ici l'assemblée nationale depuis
le 5 janvier en effet luis parlera lui
aussi est député de l'opposition
revendique le perchoir du président
autoproclamé affaibli dans son pays
elle les appelle à manifester
mi-novembre de roanne why do sont
restées lettre morte
juan gouaille d'eau poursuit donc sa
tournée européenne
ici à paris pour demander de l'aide
seuls nous n'y arriverons pas c'est ce
qu'il a déclaré cette semaine au forum
économique de davos en suisse mercredi
il avait été accueilli à bruxelles par
les dirigeants européens des dirigeants
et qui n'ont pas annoncé de mesures
concrètes pour influencer le processus
politique dans son pays
l'année 2020 s'annonce donc assez
compliqué pour pourquoi noyau